grand chef bison couché et c'est
vaillant guerrier attaquer les visages
pâles
bison couchés n'écoute jamais la parole
d'espoir
[Musique]
ah oui ça oui oui
les Indiens je n'entends que ça depuis
un quart d'heure je crois j'en ai les
oreilles qui bourdonnent non mais ce
n'est pas tellement ça la façon dont
aimer on m'a envoyé promener se préparer
ah oui oh non non mais ça c'est rien non
non mais c'est parce que il est
tellement pris par son rôle de chef
indien qui qui seront plus trop bien
compte de ce que tu monsieur rien et on
va attaquer François
les Indiens
[Musique]
il est tellement dans son personnage que
il ne se rend pas compte de très bien de
ce qu'il fait
j'ai compris quand même c'est beaucoup
plus grande de crever mes ballons que de
toute réalité de soi ah c'est en opinion
mais tout le monde n'attache pas la même
importance au chaud
Julie tu as entendu quasimir attaque le
facteur maintenant bison couché prendre
les messages les messages des visages
pas la langue fourchue ne doivent pas
arriver à fortiosque
on a pas le droit visage pâle venez
donner donnez-leur de la banque donnez
lors de la banque
[Musique]
laisse-le
calme-toi enfin très bien bisous coucher
abandonné devant la charge du 8e de
cavalerie mais grand chef bison couché
reviendra c'est ça c'est ça
merci François merci rien de casser
facteur
je ne sais pas aujourd'hui j'ai envie
d'embêter tout le monde
ah ça ce sont des choses qui arrivent tu
t'es levé du mauvais pied mais je n'ai
pas de mauvais qui sont tous les deux
trains mignons mes pieds mais quasiment
je n'attaque pas tes pieds c'est une
expression ça veut dire se lever de
mauvaise humeur ah bon
d'ailleurs j'ai un remède pour toi et
lequel la recette de la sagesse musica
[Musique]
je voudrais bien savoir comment il faut
faire pour devenir sage être toujours en
bénissant comme les enfants sur les
images
surtout quand on est comme moi avec des
rêves plein la tête on a déjà est
maladroit s'il te plaît dis moi la
recette
en vérité fait plaisir à tout ce que tu
as aimé
et c'est gagné tu deviens sage sans le
savoir et même tu es heureux de rendre
les gens autour de toi
c'est merveilleux quand le soleil habite
sous à toi
il arrive de temps en temps de partir en
claquant la porte ce n'est pas que je
sois méchant c'est la colère qui
m'entend
et ben ça faut que
il arrive que je me bagarre avec les
meilleurs de mes copains et je tape sans
crier
fait plaisir à tout ce que tu aimes
et c'est gagné tu deviens ça je sens le
savoir et même
tu es heureux de rendre les gens autour
de toi
c'est merveilleux quand le soleil pique
sous un toit
alors je veux bien essayer pour diminuer
mes bêtises de faire plaisir au monde
entier ce sera dur quoi que tu
dises car consommatrice
[Musique]
font aussi parfois des erreurs
je voudrais bien savoir comment il faut
faire pour devenir sage être toujours
obéissant comme les enfants sur les
images
surtout quand on est comme moi avec des
rêves plein la tête qu'on a déjà est mal
à droite mais j'ai bien compris la
recette
salut
bonjour David fait très attention avec
ton Thomas Waka tu pourrais blesser un
autre enfant sois prudent
[Musique]
depuis un moment
est une sagesse qui ne gentillesse
exemple tout ça c'est grâce à ma méthode
ah oui tu veux parler de ta recette de
la sagesse la chanson oui elle a une
sorte de pouvoir magique sur lui chaque
fois que nous la chantons il devient
sage il a bien observé j'ai même
l'impression qu'après l'avoir entendu à
chaque fois il est encore plus sage que
la fois précédente tu as raison on
dirait que le pouvoir grandit au fur et
à mesure il devient de plus en plus sage
voilà mademoiselle futait sa
m'étonnerait beaucoup qu'avec elle il
reste aussi sage et aussi serviable
qu'en ce moment surtout si elle
l'appelle son petit canari rose bonjour
Julie bonjour François bonjour à tous
bonjour mademoiselle
bonjour les qui me parlent c'est moi
votre petit canari rose
si vous préférez m'appeler votre petite
mésange bleue vous pouvez ou alors votre
petit chaton
mauve ou votre petit sanglier gripper là
ou votre lapin vert pomme
oui
j'adore j'aurais aimé être vers toi mais
malheureusement tout le monde m'aurait
pris pour une grenouille enfin mais si
vous préférez m'appeler votre petit
léopardiez m'appeler tu es très gentil
je me demande si ta recette ne commence
pas faire un petit peu trop d'effet sur
Casimir je crois que tu as raison
François Casimir devient trop sage et
voilà
ne bougez pas restez là je reviens vous
devez avoir très chaud je vais vous
rafraîchir que faire
et si nous nous trouvions
[Musique]
le plus en sécurité
est devenu très gentil
en facteur je suis si content de vous
voir
mais tout le plaisir est pour moi vous
devez avoir très chaud ah ça tu peux le
dire pour sûr mais justement je languis
d'aller prendre une douche après ce
soleil
ne bougez pas facteur vos désirs sont
désordre
voilà voilà
je vais également vous repasser votre
travail
tout ceci est pour votre bien
franchement Casimir à ce propos s'il te
plaît arrête d'être sage vous y
comprenez quelque chose vous
[Musique]